[Music]
one little dog is creating a really
uncomfortable way of living which the
people have to become sore antisocial to
the rest of the world because this 35
pound dog is creating this chaos
[Music]
so I'm gonna do it again a bigger dog
would it go over right over like this
this is dominance this is not being
aggressive there's just been dominance
right he has a weapon that is his mouth
I don't so this is my shield right this
is what I mean I'm using the environment
to help him to calm down to let him know
that this male human being is not afraid
of him and I mean no harm that's at the
moment I move away he went into the
state and I came back and challenged him
again all right that's why you can't try
this at home
[Music]
she's not backing away he's calming down
yeah that's the really good look at that
look at the eye contact now this he's
giving me submissive eye contact that's
when you do things right
see now the shaking part it's an
expression of coping with the new self
okay
they're so addictive to be aggressive
that when somebody blocks them they go
into it what should i do I don't know
how to be in any other way so seeing the
shaking is part of the intervention
years back telling her he's unsure
just be good
fight another another protest behavior
as you saw he has learned to control
situation with his feet very typical of
the breed and his mouth he's gonna chew
through it their food right there that
you guys keep seeing like that okay this
is an expression of going after somebody
hunter predator so he is a little unsure
submissive that's what we can trust them
yes
[Music]